[Music]
whoa take it easy there Pathfinder you
might be feeling a little dizzy or
lightheaded this is normal for anyone
who just woke up from a 600 year nap
your memory might be a little fuzzy as
well so let me catch you up on our
Andromeda protocol and what you need to
know before you start exploring our new
home if you're a Mass Effect fan make
sure to check out our behind-the-scenes
documentary on Andromeda hit that
subscribe button so you don't miss a
thing
once you've thought out we'll let you
loose to explore yose and other sweet
planets I can't show you right now there
are a few things to keep in mind first
the environment is hostile not only do
you have to deal with creatures like
this
but you also have to worry about weather
and radiation
heõs has a radiation problem if you
wander too far from a safe area or the
nomads you'll get fried based on what
we've played it seems like these
environmental issues clear up as you
progress through the story but there are
some hazards that your Nomad won't even
protect you from access issues equipment
nearby speaking of your Nomad it's your
trusty 6 wheel steed no you can't
whistle it over to you like a horse if
you lose it but you can fast travel to a
drop pod and call it in the planets
you'll be exploring are huge so it's in
your best interest not to stray too far
from your vehicle if you're having
trouble getting up an incline you can
activate six wheel drive this will slow
you down but it's the best and only way
to get this hunk of metal up a hill and
never forget if you're in a hurry to get
back to the tempest you can hold down Y
triangle or tea and you'll load right
back into your ship ascent just go
leaving Apple all clear as a pathfinder
you're expected to do some research as
well don't worry you won't be tested on
the various biomes of es but a good
Pathfinder is responsible for scanning
and cataloguing technology vegetation
and wildlife everything you scan will
net you research points for one of three
different categories Helius cluster
Milky Way and remnant you can then use
your research points of the Rd terminal
on the tempest to craft weapon and armor
blueprints once a blueprint has been
created you can Forge that item using
minerals and other resources you've
salvaged from scanning planets breaking
down weapons and armor mining with the
nomads and just good old-fashioned
picking stuff up if you think science is
dumb you can also buy weapons from
vendors but you'll be doing more than
just driving around in scanning planets
Andromeda's combat has undergone some
significant changes and the result is a
much more liberating experience
abilities can be combined in combo'd off
of each other more easily and the
jetpack adds a lot more verticality to
the battles
unfortunately the tactical commands from
the original trilogy are gone you can
still tell your squad to go here or
regroup but you can't access their
powers this means the experimentation is
largely up to you there are three
different types of abilities tech combat
and biotic personally I stick with
biotic abilities but I wouldn't ignore
tech or combat if you like to carry more
than two guns at a time invest in the
combat Fitness skill tree a basic biotic
combo is pull and throw hold down your
pull ability and once you've pulled them
up close use throw and you'll send them
off to the next Galaxy
keep in mind you can only have three
abilities mapped at a time but Andromeda
does have something called favorites
once you've assigned three powers you
like together you can favorite it now
hold the weapon select button and you
can swap between different power sets
this may not be super useful early on
but later it comes in handy and remember
if you aren't happy with the abilities
you've invested in you can always head
on over to the medical Bay in the
tempest where you can respect for a
small fee but with powers like these why
would you Andromeda also introduces a
contextual cover system to be honest
it's not great but make sure you know
how to swap shoulders while and cover
otherwise you're gonna have a bad time
luckily though movement and verticality
plays a much bigger role the recharge
time for your jump and dash are very
short so it's in your best interest to
keep moving and if you aim while in the
air you can hover and take shots at your
enemies from above even with all this
fancy movement though don't ignore cover
altogether your shield will regenerate
faster if you're hunkered down
congratulations Pathfinder you're ready
to explore the next frontier as you
research and trailblaze the Helius
cluster you'll learn a lot more tips and
tricks
leave those findings and discoveries in
the comments below to help out your
fellow pathfinders for more on Mass
Effect Andromeda make sure to subscribe
and as always thanks for watching